I sold my last company for $ 46.2
million I crossed $100 million net worth
at age 32 and I just made my biggest
investment ever by becoming the co-owner
of school and I always wanted breakdown
videos from Jeff basos and Warren
Buffett and Elon Musk what were they
thinking like of course they're 100
billion now but I want to know what they
were thinking at 100 million and 10
million I want to show you what the
thought process is behind the investment
and most importantly how you can model
that decision-making framework to make
way more money in your life I decided to
invest in school and make my single
largest investment to date including
putting my brand behind it and endorsing
the company
because there's multiple things that are
aligned in the same direction so Charlie
Munger talks about this he calls it the
LA laaloa effect and so usually when you
get these like massive explosive growth
opportunities it's not because of one
thing so a lot of people want to have a
silver bullet so it's kind of like a
silver bullet fallacy it's thinking that
there's this one big thing that if we
just do that then everything else will
work and more times than not it's the
hundred golden BB's no silver bullets
it's two three five six things that all
have an incremental boost but when you
multiply all them together create this
insane outcome and so I see that with
school and so let me Zoom all the way
back out to like the ecosystem so this
would be like big thing number one if we
look at the education industry so let me
let me show you some math real quick
education
globally is 10
trillion big all right us is 1.3
trillion still very big now this is
split between two things you've got
formal education so that would be like
twoyear and fouryear degrees and right
now that's around depending on the
source 850 billion and for those of you
who Google and find out that it's 863 or
another source this is 842 it doesn't
matter because in this type of stuff
that we're talking about we're talking
about big forces and we're talking about
directional corre Ness but it's around
850 billion for formal education now on
the other side it's split you've got
e-learning in online education I'll put
it that alternative
education which right now is about
250ish billion 200 to 250ish billion
depending on your Source all right so
close to that now here's the really
interesting thing about this and this
will relate to why I'm betting really
big on school or at least one of the
reasons
is that this one is shrinking by 6% per
year kind of
interesting this one is growing by about
$40
billion per
year now that is because this one's
growing at roughly 20% per year so
you've got this massive nut here that's
shrinking by 6% all right which is about
what's the math here about $50 billion
is what it's losing every year and we've
got this other one that's gaining $40
billion a year and growing at
20% so when I see these two things and I
see this big overall industry in terms
of 1.3 trillion 1.2 trillion
whatever I see this as actually a
crisscross so formal is continuing to go
down and alternative or e-learning Etc
is continuing to go up and so it's
almost the exact amount that this loses
every single year is almost the same
amount that this one is gaining every
single year and so that underpins a
shift in buying Behavior people are
seeing more and more that formal
education doesn't give the return that
it was promising and people are able to
learn skills directly that can
contribute to them making more money and
being able to contribute in society feed
their families pay their rents pay their
mortgages and ultimately just live
productive lives and so if you're a hair
stylist you're like well you know what
the the formal education thing doesn't
matter because all I have to do is like
learn how to like post on Instagram like
my clients that even I do in my garage
and I get more DMS for people who want
me to do that and not a single
customer's ever asked me for what my
certification was huh so maybe this
skill is more valuable than this skill
huh and this girl is willing to teach me
how she does it for 1,000 bucks whereas
this school is 2 years and 15
grand well well the ROI is not there
right and so what's happening is a lot
of this money that has been going to
these big endowments these these hars
these these big university money now I
do think at the top those guys are
probably protected for a while but it's
like the mediocre middle it's CCU state
right like those are the ones that have
four-year degrees that don't mean
anything that no one cares about all of
that money is getting actually pushed
all the way back down to the bottom to
basically creators people who are good
at teaching a niche skill they're like
hey I did this thing it worked well for
me here's how you can do it and that
works for anything whether it's like
you're selling a customer like hey I
lost this weight this is how I did it I
ate all meat all the time and somebody
else is like I only ate plants whatever
and if that sounds cool to you I can
show you how I did it and so this
industry is Contin to grow so when I see
this I think okay huge amount of money
Changing Hands in a very fast time zone
I'd rather be in this
boat than in this boat and so that's
thing number one so that's kind of the
industry overall now if you look at me
personally like how do I intersect with
this well the first two companies that I
sold so gym launch and Prestige Labs
well I'd sold companies before that but
they were just low seven fig numbers not
bigger numbers those companies service
creators and as somebody who came from
first a direct response marketing
background and selling media and
Licensing uh to Brick and Mortar gyms
I'm really familiar with this model like
there is no University for gyms and so I
did my best to create that University
for gym owners because if you went to
school for being a gym owner you'd make
a heck of a lot more money than if you
just went to school for like business
and then opened a gym I have lived
through this huge shift in wealth
because like I started I think when I
was 27 years old I think we took home
$16 million in income just capitalizing
on this trend and so I know that that
money is out there and people are
starving for information that they can
actually use to feed themselves and so I
have the big Trend data that I can see
on the charts and the big fancy Finance
people but I also have my personal
anecdote of having experienced that huge
amount of wealth coming towards me so
that's thing number two thing number
three is where do I fit in with this
ecosystem and so my audience for the
most part is split between business
owners and people who'd like to start a
business my whole mission with making
the content that we do has been to make
real business accessible for everyone
and so early on for me I didn't have a
lot of mentors and help and so I just
looked everywhere I could to learn this
stuff and I learned a lot of it the hard
way one of the reasons that I put this
stuff out there is that also some of the
sources that exist out there are just
honestly false like they are teaching
things they have not done they're
regurgitating content from other people
and getting key points wrong because
they don't know why it's right to to
begin with and just basically leading
people astray and I actually don't think
it's malicious I think they just want
the views they want the likes they want
the ad Revenue whatever and like I don't
blame whatever I would like to at least
put stuff out there that I know like I
have done this and I have done it many
times and so if you follow this process
whether you're a good person or a bad
person it will probably work for you and
so my audience knows that my whole goal
has been to make real business
successible for everyone and so if we're
thinking okay Alex you could have
promoted I don't know pick something
Drop Shipping like there's a lot of
different things I could have done but
why why School particularly well because
the mission of school aligns with my
personal mission which is to make real
business successful for everyone they
want to like School want myself included
now I'm a co-owner want to make business
fund and easy for everyone and so I
spent six months talking to the founder
about like what do you really want this
to become and he has a huge massive
vision and his vision aligns with my
vision of how big I think the space
really is if you think about all the
different industries that exist most of
them have been disrupted by technology
in some in some way you've got like
Airbnb so hotels got attacked by Airbnb
taxis got attacked by Uber these are the
famous examples right but there isn't if
you think about it no one's disrupted
education no like there's no one place
that everyone goes to learn stuff it's
still completely fragmented and as
somebody who's been in that space and
understands that space very well and
sees the trend
I believe that there will be someone who
will take it and my bet is that school
will be that company now why School
versus the zillions so this is like I
guess point4 which comes down to why
this particular company this particular
product and hopefully even going through
this the thought process you can still
relate to any major decision that you
have to make in your life and so why
School particularly one of my big litmus
tests for something a product that I'm
going to promote is that I want it to
grow on its own meaning if the only way
that a company grows is that it
advertises and when it stops advertising
it goes down I don't like that I like to
have passive growth and so let's go over
here and I'll walk you through it so
there's something that I call the golden
ratio in business you have the
percentage of customers who refer
customers and the percentage of
customers who uh exit so these people
exit these people refer and and if the
percentage of people who leave every
month so this is 0.1 so 10% all right
I'll just I'll put as these percentages
rather than decimals there you go bear
with me if 10% of my customers refer me
a new customer every month and 10% leave
every month then my business will stay
the same now if 20% of my customers
refer me a customer every month and the
same 10% exit my business over whatever
this interval of time is Will 2x 2 over
one and that means that no matter how
big I get the business will consist
consistently double every one of those
time
intervals and so I look very carefully
at what percentage of customers decide
to bring other customers to the business
and what percentage are leaving or
choosing not to buy again and this works
whether you're selling physical products
this works whether you're selling
software it works whether you're selling
services it works the same way and so
this golden ratio of percentage of
referrals over percentage of people who
leave or churn is what tells you the
passive growth rate of a business now
the vast like vast majority of
businesses
they've got let's call it you know 2% of
people are referring and they've got you
know 10% of people that are leaving and
so they have to fill this bucket up with
ads or or marketing or Outreach or
whatever it is that they have to do to
fill up the top side so that they just
don't lose everyone over time and that's
because they don't understand how to
build a good product now once you have a
company that does this and does have
more people who refer than leave every
month that is when
you this is a
flame that's when you pour gas on this
thing and you say okay now I want to
tell the world about it so that that
number of doubles it just goes dot dot
dot do Dot and then it doubles off the
chart and then you add even more and
then doubles again off the chart because
you're just increasing the nend as fast
as you can so that the doubling happens
on a bigger amount of customers so when
I saw school's metrics I was blown away
I had never seen a company who had
metrics as good as school to like I've
never in my history of looking and we
look at a lot of businesses we get gosh
several thousand businesses a month that
reach out at acquisition. comom for
investment and for us to to buy you know
a minority or majority of the of the
business and so I've looked at a lot of
business metrics and so when I saw the
passive growth rate that school had it
really intrigued me and so that business
underlying fundamentals were there the
mission of the fact that it wanted to
make Business Online easy and fun and it
starts right now in the education space
like all of those things made it really
really a good fit for me now let's talk
about uh Enterprise Value stuff so
number five I am here to make money and
so I I I like to have my my altruistic
goal is to make real business education
accessible for everyone but guess what
we have a lot of people work at this
company a lot and you know unfortunately
you guys you know want to eat feed
yourselves have
girlfriends and uh boyfriends hey you
know uh and uh and and have houses and
cars damn you right and so these guys
need money unfortunately I would do this
for free but they need money and so uh
money is obviously a component of uh of
any business so let me let me walk you
through um the difference here so let's
say that I have a traditional business
number one so let's call this a service
business and let's say I'm just going to
use Simple Math here all right I'm going
to try not to do too much math because I
know everyone hates math right which by
the way get over that because if you
want to make money but let's say that
we've got a $10 million business that
does Topline and it does 3 million in
profit okay cool now a traditional
service business like this might be a
$15 million business so that's just
giving a five times multiple to the
business which by the way that's how
businesses are valued is usually a
multiple of earnings and so cool this is
a 15 million do company now if I double
this company and go from you know 10 to
20 and 3 to 6 then I go this goes into
becomes a $30 million business more or
less might get a little bit more maybe
get 6X cuz it's a little bigger but more
or less I have this Delta that I can add
to the
business now if I had an e-commerce
business my multiple might be on top
line but it might be a little bit higher
so if it was the same numbers 10 and
three then this company might trade at
call it three time you know two times
Topline so this might be a two times
Topline business 2x in terms of how the
how it's valued so this might be a $20
million business at Baseline and again
if I double this business then it goes
to $40 million okay well that went from
increasing by 15 million to increasing
by 20 million so if I owned this
business me putting the same effort in I
would make more money neat now let's
look at this third piece and then I'm
going to tie this together for
you let's say say we have a tx/ software
business and these
businesses
trade and all of these trading multiples
depend on all the fundamental business
second Ops I'm trying to keep this
really simple on High level because I
want the decision-making process to be
the highlight more than the individual
numbers all right but if a business
again is $10 million Topline and $3
million of profit let's
say they might get somewhere between 10
to 20x their Topline and so this might
be somewhere in the neighbor of 100 to
$200
million now let's say I double this
business and we go from 200 to $400
million well then we created $200
million in value so we created $15
million by doubling this one $20 million
by doubling this one $200 million by
doubling this one so if you're going to
put effort somewhere and it's the same
amount of
work you get more for what you put in
and that's fundamentally like the
acis.com logo is about leverage so like
the the it looks like this is our logo
and that's because this is a lever and
the main point there is that you get
more for what you put in and so one of
my big things in life the reason we be
able to move quickly in terms of
accumulating material wealth is making
sure that when we make the move we get
the most for it and so obviously I've
spent four or five years building an
audience and not really promoting
anything or any of the companies that I
own but this one felt too close to what
so so many people needed which is they
wanted a way to make their first
business they wanted to make a way to
make their first dollar online um for me
the the mission was aligned they want to
make it fun and easy for everybody just
like I want to make business successible
for everyone it had the fundamentals
of the big Market behind it so it's
moving in the right direction I'm on the
right
wave and the business itself was sound
it was a really good product so I felt
for my brand that if I'm going to
promote something it had to be really
good because if people say I'm only
trying this because of Alex and they get
in there and it sucks who do they think
sucks me I'm the one who introduced them
right like if you had a friend who's
like oh you got to use S Sally she's a
great hair stylist and you go and Sally
just gives you a bus cut and puts your
hair as blue and you're like but I
wanted my hair to be red right forget
the bus guy um you'd be upset you'd be
like Sally what the hell this person's
crazy right and so you be upset at the
person who referred to and so the same
degree I had to take that kind of I had
to take this even at a higher level cuz
I'm also a business owner so like I've
I've been referred companies and I've
like oh it's pretty good obviously
there's things they could improve but
like I know that the internet um has a
short memory and has low forgiveness and
so I had to make sure it was something
that I could really get behind which is
why it's honestly I've been looking for
something that I could get behind for
years there's just nothing that met the
met the standard um that I have for you
guys honestly I got very excited about
that and so after six months we decided
to do the deal and I talked about this
big decision that I was going to make in
an earlier Vlog was like my billion
dollar my billion dollar decision it was
about school was whether or not I was
going to invest in school and
specifically also promote it and like
actually talk publicly about it but it
felt too big and like it would help too
many people for me not to do it and so
um that was ultimately why I made the
decision now if you listening to this I
have two camps right we have business
owners and we have people who want to
start a business and so I want to share
some cool metrics uh at least they get
me very excited about this and for the
future that if you want to start a
business even if you have a business
that you'll find interesting and that
could probably make you money all right
because we now like now I'm a co-owner
of the platform I have access to a lot
of information that other people don't
have and so we ran something that we
wanted to call the school games and so
so this was something that Sam and I
came up with together we were like how
do we make this fun like how do we make
this cool and so we're like like it has
to be it has to be something more than
just try this out right and so we're
like What if we gave away what everyone
else charges for which is usually my
like go-to like how do I how do I look
at what everyone else charges for make
it better make it free like that's been
my I'll write that process out like look
what everyone else is charging for make
it better make it free all right like if
you want to get customers that's the
Playbook now so with the school games
what we did was I said okay what what
does everyone else give away oops school
games well most people have like
coaching calls whatever you want to call
it so people charge for that uh they
have courses right they have courses
they put inside all and they charge for
that uh they have a community these are
all C's that's kind of nice uh they have
a community um that they have uh in
involved there and then uh I want to
have another one so I'm I I want to keep
it to C's uh but so they have code which
is realistically they have tools right
so they have tools that they give people
right and so it's like okay if someone
has expert help they have doy self
training they have support from other
people doing the same thing which this
also builds out there here's another C
for you builds their conviction because
in the beginning making your first
dollar online so little of it has to do
with making their first dollar and so
much of it has to do with getting out of
your own head which is why a lot of
people were trying to get into business
start with personal development first
because they have to get through all
their fears of rejection and why their
dad didn't love them and why they're
doing this to begin with and what's my
passion blah blah blah blah blah right
all you got to do is make a dollar and
then you're in business just FYI so
these are all the things that people
charge for and we're like
okay well let's just make it
free and so that's pretty much what the
school games was about it was giving all
of this stuff uh and so we do I think
three a week with all the top Community
owners so this isn't uh so this is the
people actually doing it and the nice
thing with school because we own the
platform we know no one's fronting we
see all the numbers and so and all the
numbers are public so no one can claim
that they're like I'm making a million
dollars a month they're like dude you're
right there I can see how you I see what
what you make right and so it just keeps
everything honest and transparent in an
industry that lacks a lot of that and so
my hope also Sams as well is to is to
bring transparency to an industry that's
been very shrouded uh in in just lack of
transparen just lies honestly in
deception I would say misrepresentation
would be the the correct word for that
so we do all that stuff and we said uh
we'll make it 30 days and so I'll give
you the the business explanation behind
this so we did 14 days for free in a
30-day games that way people have two
weeks if they're like you know what this
isn't working for me they can dip out if
they do think it's working for them and
they finish the games then they can the
top 10 people fly out um to Vegas and we
help them grow their their communities
and and learn from them see how we can
make the product better things like that
now this is the part that uh might
interest
you well hopefully that interested you
too but this might interest you so I got
the stats from the first games um and
3.44% of people finished the first month
of the games so they they went to 30
days
made their first dollar
online so just under one out of three
people made their first dollar or more
obviously um who finished their first
month after the school games and that to
me was like the most excited I've ever
been finding this out because I
obviously like I have so many people in
our community who want to start
businesses and I was like how can we
make this as easily as seemly possible
it's like okay well there's no other
piece of software that has to get used
you don't have to learn anything else it
processes the money it helps you with
the delivery it's all in one place like
there's nothing else that's needed like
you can run the entire business on the
platform um and you can start for free
and so that's what got me really excited
about it and so I'll explain the
business model to you guys if you're
interested in terms of uh how I'll
explain how School works and I'll
explain how uh the school like hosts
work so school is just a $99 month
platform and longterm that's not the
monetization place I just like to
explain um where it is so right now it's
$99 a month um and we keep it that way
because we just want it to be simple
like if we wanted to maximize profit we
would have lots of tiers and we could do
you know a ton of other things believe
me to make more money with the system
that's just not the objective right now
the objective right now is to get as
many students on the platform and as
many teachers on the platform so that we
just create a richer and Rich community
of content so that we can tackle that 10
trillion dollar Global nut of Education
because if people can go to one place to
learn whatever they want from people who
are actually doing it and they'll do it
affordably compared to $50,000 a year or
whatever you know CCU charges that is a
bet that I'm willing to make and so
right now we're in growth
mode and
so that's the model it's just however
many groups there are is the times 99 is
what is how how much money the platform
makes and the platform has been losing
money because we've been aggressively
reinvesting in getting better and better
software engineers and designers and
developers to make the product
absolutely exceptional so that's why
obviously I wrote a big check into it
because I want it to happen I wanted to
to crush in we will like it's doing
really well so we're good there but
let's talk about you so if you if you
were to start a school Community because
a lot of people who follow my stuff are
like well I would like to start a
business and um if you think this is
okay then I might give this a shot so
I'll just explain how the business model
works so you've got
this is my Instagram my Instagram icon
man this is going to be tough let's see
if I see if I can I know all of
them that's that's Tik Tok I think and
then you got Facebook right you got
Facebook all right whatever that's good
enough so you got social media so you
got traffic you got eyeballs all right
so just think about this like this you
got
eyeballs that you have to go get now you
can get those in any ways you want you
can post you can run ads you can do
Outreach you can partner with somebody
who already has an audience all of these
are ways to to fundly just get eyeballs
and so then you drive those
eyeballs to your school page so this is
why this is kind of neat so I'll explain
this to you so our vision for this is
that like we just turned on ad tracking
this last month so it's kind of exciting
is that if you think about the
difference between Shopify and Amazon
okay so Shopify let's say I sold a pens
I sell these markers okay so that's my
product I sell these markers and I sell
on Shopify well I'm going to to
customize the whole page I'm going have
to learn the Integrations I'm going to
have to build all this stuff but I have
a lot more control all right so that's
that's the the plus is that you get a
lot more control a lot more
customization the downside is it's a lot
harder uh and there's no inherent brand
trust so if you just throw up a shop
store with pens why should I buy from
you not a really compelling reason
although in The Other Extreme you have
like Amazon so I'm the same same guy
selling pens but I put on Amazon now I
can't control the color the reviews the
I can't control anything I just know
that I have to use the template that
Amazon has and I put this on there but
here's an interesting stat for you so I
have a book I have multiple books1 in
$100 mil Ser $100 offers $ leads and
another one coming out soon um and so my
Shopify page converts at like 2 to 3%
something like that which is like fairly
standard for
e-commerce my Amazon page that has the
same book converts at
30% so 10 times as efficient in terms of
converting now Amazon obviously takes
its fee for you know doing the
transaction
whatever but the key point is that
because what happens is you start to
build inherent trust in the platform and
so as people begin to trust School more
and do more and more transactions on
school then these School pages will
convert better than any page that you
could possibly build on your own because
you get to borrow school's
credibility that's the key point and so
if you're trying to get into business
like number one way to make lots of
money just have amaz like a massive huge
brand of and an audience okay but if
you're trying to get into that it's like
uh it's like telling a model like how do
I be successful it's like be born
beautiful like like how do I be born how
to be a great musician like be born a
great musician whatever point is is that
we can actually help arm people who are
getting into business by letting them
borrow our brand credibility and because
of this it also becomes way lower
technologically in terms of difficulty
for somebody who's starting out
interestingly it's like if you look at
Amazon l Zillow you look at
Airbnb they almost all more or less
converge at the same overall layout
you've got a video right you've got a
video you usually got a carousel of
images you've got you got some
reviews for the thing you've got a buy
button and then usually a handful of
bullets about the product almost all of
the pages look like that and so by the
way if you're going to build something
maybe something to consider that those
guys have more traffic and conversion
data than anyone on Earth they built it
that way for a reason and so the school
page looks the same way that way you can
build it that way so you get your
eyeballs whatever you want you drive it
towards the school page which probably
convert better than anything you make on
your own and
then you have your community so you've
got all your people inside your
community and they're all happy and they
look like they have dresses on cool
whatever and so and so then you provide
value this people and this becomes a
recurring Revenue stream and they pay
whatever between you know $1 and 9999
whatever per
month and that's it and the reason I
like this model overall too is that it
it creates a way for people to provide
value to people with low risk like if
you say hey I need $50,000 to for you to
do this thing with me it's a big risk if
you don't know anything if you haven't
consumed anything but this allows people
to have a front end that with low risk
someone can come in learn about them get
value and then if they want they can
choose to ascend to higher levels or
that just becomes the main thing and
they just drive tons and tons of volume
through it people have won in either of
those scenarios but this is
fundamentally like the simplest business
model I could possibly imagine for
someone's trying to get started you
don't need inventory you don't need any
third party Integrations you don't need
to know anything about technology and
you can actually make your money on the
platform so this is from Evelyn I just
want to read this to you because I think
it it'll it'll say better than I can she
said $99 a month worth it I think you
need to understand this I keep seeing
post questioning if $99 this is inside
the school games if $99 for Community is
worth it and if you should go with a
free Facebook group instead I didn't see
or understand uh this when I started on
school but if you want to actually build
a community of a meaningful size you
need to hear this um I have deep regrets
yesterday I was listening to Matt
Thompson and his latest podcast when one
thing really struck me that I want to
share with you it's insane how much
Community Management cost you save when
you use School versus a Facebook group
for context in my own communities we
manage over 11,000 paying monthly
members and combined with my other
business partner over
20,000 because there is a no payment
integration and B Facebook restricts our
paid reach down to an average of 300 out
of 6,500 members in our biggest group so
you have this group of people and you
can't actually reach them that
sucks but that's the prevailing that's
like what's currently out there and if
you want to have payments it doesn't
integrate with anything you can't do it
right and so we have to pay team of
people to a find and remove people who
don't pay because Facebook doesn't do
that automatically like school does and
then B provide 24-hour workday written
support because school members in
contrast School members actually see
each other's posts and want to help each
other out because of the gam
gamification element and the connection
that comes from having to start to
engage and so some of the things that
school has which is why it's growing at
the rate that it is is that we've put
gamification inside of it and so people
get points for getting likes and getting
comments but to them to themselves and
so they gain a status in the community
like in real terms they gain status and
then that status actually unlocks other
abilities like a game and so the core of
the development team at school is
actually all gaming developers because
we wanted to make business fun and so we
wanted to make it like a game because
there's so many people that I see
especially younger people but just
people in general who are absolutely
insane at different games and I'm like
dude if you just took this level of
focus and applied it to business you'd
already be a millionaire like no doubt
in my mind but no one's just taken
business and tried to turn it into a
game and so that is absolutely the
vision of what we're trying to do is how
do we make this fun and easy for
everyone how do we just take the bar
that's already low and just make it that
much lower so that way more people can
cross cross it like you don't have to be
this tall to ride this ride anymore you
just have to be this tall right that's
the idea and so she says honestly this
is so genius our community is now one of
our the the community she built on
school is our most profitable community
because one we don't run ads to it at
the moment 234 members of net growth in
the first month after playing the school
games all organically from school
Discovery page in this community so one
of the cool things about school is that
it's a platform and so what that means
is that like when you have a community
this ranks in our directory of
communities and so just like Google
ranks web pages we rank communities and
so people will go to learn things they
want to learn how to do plumbing at home
or they want to learn how to fix their
roof or they want to learn how to play
ping pong or the watercolor whatever and
they go there and click watercoloring
groups and then the groups that come up
they joined but the people who own those
groups didn't generate that customer we
did again this is you borrowing off of
school and so we can actually help
people get customers as well which is
one of the again one of the cool things
that I like about the platform she had
234 new member net so that means net of
turn people who left people she added
234 without any paid ads pretty cool and
so the second reason that it's more
profitable is that we haven't paid we
haven't promised 24-hour ritten support
and don't deliver it because members are
helping members and it's working
amazingly here I'm really mindblown this
would never been possible with a
Facebook group it might be the amazing
Community the lower cost or the fact
that I can finally reach my own
Community again but I'm becoming a Super
Fan I say that because I think she can
say better than I can um is that if you
actually want to have a business and
this is the hard part about being being
a beginner is that if you actually are
successful then you will run into new
problems later and so school unfort like
for me as a marketer this is the worst
position to Market from because no one
is suffering from the problem yet but
you will suffer from the problem if you
actually win it's like if you lose
weight you're going to have to change
the clothes out of your wardrobe because
nothing's going to fit anymore but
people are still so focused on losing
weight that they don't think about the
next thing but I'm telling you that if
you follow the steps and you you become
one of the 30% right of
people who make their first dollar right
3.44 make their first dollar well then
when you make your second doll and5th
doll and thousandth And1 10,000th
quickly you're like oh shoot I wish I
had started this on a platform that
already knew how to scale and with
school you can start the right way from
the GetGo rather than rather than have a
switch later and so big
picture I decided to make this bet on
school because it was growing Without Me
based on Word of Mouth it's harnessing a
huge Trend in the industry in terms of
Education
overall I personally know a lot about
education have made a lot of my wealth
in education
um and so I felt uniquely qualified to
help the company grow fourth my brand
has been built and my mission has been
about making real business education
accessible for everyone and until now I
haven't seen anything that actually
really anybody or any team that even
came close to the level of dedication
that school's team has and also the
level of talent exceptionally talented
stacked developer team like A+ talent
and uh we're able to make a platform
right now that handles currently
millions of users every month Millions
many millions of users every month and
it just works seamlessly and so for
those reasons and because now I have the
data to support this so just to be
really clear the first four things is
why I made the bet the fifth one which
is what I just showed you the 34 3.44%
of people who make their first dollar
after their first month of school like
that's what just gets me even more Jazz
that it was the right call and for those
of you who are business owners as a side
note almost every existing business
would benefit from having a community in
one place so whether you're a real
estate agent or where you just want to
have a place that you can just spoil
your customers they get to know each
other you make introductions that means
you add value and the cool thing with
communities is that the members add
value to each other that's like what the
concept of a network effect is is
there's a network effect like people
each when somebody else gets added to
the group it actually adds value to
everyone else so if there's one person
in a in in a community there's no
network if there's two great when you
add a third person both of these people
benefit from the new party when you had
a fourth person all three benefit from
the fourth and that's one of the cool
cool Parts about this and so if you're a
business owner and like I said whether
you're a real estate agent or you're
you're a plumber or you're or you're a
gym owner or you have a salon and you do
hair it doesn't really matter having a
place where all your customers can be
together without worrying about like the
craziness of like Facebook and some of
the other social media platforms that
exist and know that you can curate the
entire experience uh just the way you
want it and you can reach 100% of your
customers every single time you make a
post
um and they can you can reach out to
them you can DM them you can do all
these things uh you can host the the
content you can have calls regular basis
all that kind of stuff and they are
incentivized to engage in there and
that's one of the big lifts of the
platform is that people are incentivized
to engage and I'll tell you it's it's
wildly addicting because I'm in this I'm
obviously in school as well and I'm in
the school games Community for everybody
who starts it's 14 days it's free I want
to see my little ranking go up I was
like I own the platform I was like I got
to up high
ranking and so I'm I'm I'm I'm in there
posting and engaging more than I do on
any other platform more or less uh that
is why I decided to uh to make this big
bet and make it public uh because I do
think this will be our this will be my
one of the paths that we uh they create
a billion or Plus in net worth and I
hope that people look back at this video
and be like wow Alex looks so dumb then
but now he's a billionaire so it sounds
cool um and so I wanted I wanted to have
that and so I'm going to I'm I'm
committing I'm going for monthly um I'd
like to give updates of the the cool
stuff that that's happening kind of from
a business perspective so that you can
see us build this 1 billion 10 billion
hundred billion dollar Enterprise so
let's do this so I have my team here
they just heard me talk through that and
so I just told them write down your
questions and so when I'm done I'll
answer them and so this is the questions
that they had while I was presenting
this so so you get it like we really
just do this in real time all right so
shoot the traditional education it's
very centralized right a big play
billions and billions of dollars is the
e-learning more distributed is it is it
an easier playing field for the little
guys who don't know what they're doing
yet yeah 100% so so a lot of markets
basically it's a cycle of centralization
decentralization that happens over and
over and over again and so right now
like all the power was centralized and
so if you look at like Rome right the
Roman Empire like is all centralized and
then you start the Barbarians at the
gates that are all these tribes that are
independently none of them could take on
the power of Rome but in aggregate
attacking from all these different
angles they just start nibbling away at
it so a lot of Empires and
centralization doesn't lose in one big
coup I mean obviously in the political
scene sometimes it does but it often
erodes so it's little itty bitty
Snippets little crumbs that get broken
off but the the cookie is so big that
the crumbs are actually the size of this
building right like they're big crumbs
um and the reason that the smaller
competitor can beat the larger
competitor right now is two main things
well I'll say three one is to beat the
larger competitor you don't have to
offer more classes than Harvard you just
to have just have to know one thing
better than how they teach that one
thing or whether they teach it at all
and so if I am the best pottery maker
and I have a whole Instagram or social
media or YouTube channel whatever of me
making these insane pots who are they
going to who are people in general going
to want to learn from just generic
teacher number six at CCU who teaches
Pottery or the the largest pottery
YouTube or Instagram person in the world
well probably that person so number one
number two what's the cost difference so
this is the the this is the cost
component new entrance can enter because
they don't have to have a building they
don't have to employ anyone if you have
an iPhone and you have an internet
connection you can be you can get famous
you can distribute and so distribution
which is three so cost of delivery is
zero cost of distribution is zero and so
that's the big thing is that
distribution has been disrupted which is
fundamentally what the internet did in
general to all Industries it's just at
this moment and I honestly think the
like you guys want the I'll try not to
put my clip political cap on but the
reason that the the formal education
industry has not been disrupted or has
been more slow to be disrupted than
other ones is because the government
Prof it
up people have interest free loans they
don't have to pay for for 10 years if
that weren't there they would already be
gone like I just like the fact that the
government fronts $200,000 $100,000
$50,000 and the way it actually works is
that they back lenders so they say if
these people don't pay we'll pay you
back there's more Nuance to it but
fundamentally the government backs the
loans if it doesn't cost people money to
buy something then the incremental cost
appears to be zero it's obviously way
more and I've made videos about it but
it feels like zero because you sign a
piece of paper and then you get to go to
Disneyland for for kids and so and you
don't have to do anything for four years
and you just get free money right so you
have this discount this big big bad
thing that happens years from now but
you get all the good thing today and
that just leverages human behavior like
one cookie now more people will take it
than two cookies later just is what it
is but also side note successful people
wait for two cookies won't get into that
the reason that that centralization has
even existed is because of government
subsidized uh payments but the new
Creator can win because their content
will be more specific and deeper and
they will have proof and evidence that
they are the best at it the cost of
creating that content and or the
deliverable which is now digital
education courses calls whatever is also
free and the third one is that the cost
of Distributing that is also free and so
the barrier to entry is pretty much just
the cost of the few pieces of Technology
you have to rope together to have a
business and the crazy thing about this
is that it's the irony is that it's
never been lower risk to start a
business than today and so if you re
rewind a 100 years in
1924 you would have had to save for 15
years have a house use your house as
leverage to go to the bank and say will
you help me start this Bakery and then
the bakery had real cost and if you went
out of business you went bankrupt you
lost your reputation and then that was
it you'd be known as a failure for the
rest of your time now because of that
the stakes were higher people tried way
harder but fewer people did and so the
trade is now it's way lower buried to
entry and also a lot of people who have
no work ethic can get into it but it
also requires the same amount of work
but less
risk you still have to work just as hard
as you did however long ago but you
don't need to risk as much to get it and
I think that's pretty cool and so
fundamentally that's why why the crater
economy overall is just booming because
one person won't bring down the the
system but a million tiny players will
bring down the whole thing because they
each will beat that one big player at
their tiny sliver could you break down
the math how much money could I actually
generate for well um so I want to be
really clear about claims implied claims
anything like that all this is involve
risk in general so if you pay for a
platform that's $99 a month then your
risk is $99 a month all right just to be
clear beyond that the amount of money
you make is subject to how hard you try
how much you promote but if you were to
look at and I think this is a decent
proxy if you look at some of the largest
communities that exist in General on the
internet outside of school you've got
many many communities that are at 1
million 5 million $10 million a
month and it's because you have a single
player free
distribution and basically as long as
you have a good enough product and a ton
of traffic to bring people into that
product then people will pay to be in
there and see well let me give you a
little little tip so a lot of people are
like well what do I put inside of a
community I'm going to give you a little
little tactical nugget here all right so
profit well uh which is owned by a buddy
of mine who just sold it for $250
million did a really cool
14,000 um business survey of what were
the
features that people were buying that
had the highest willingness to pay so
wtp is willingness to pay um and then I
can't remember what these four were but
basically they looked at all these
different features that people had in
communities and which ones people wanted
to buy the most versus things they
thought were par for course versus
things that they didn't really care
about at all and so it's kind of like
care vers versus willingness to pay so
if you have a lot of care so care let's
put it this way so they care a lot and
they're really willing to pay this is
where you want to be they care a lot but
they're not willing to pay means you
have to do it it's kind of like protein
in your supplement stack like people
care a lot but you're not really willing
to pay an arm and a leg for it because
it's almost like an expected right and
then on the flip side this would be the
worst thing which is like no one cares
and no one's willing to pay so don't do
anything in here and so they had things
like discounts like if you have a
community where you put like exclusive
discounts uh like merch merch was one
that was over here like some people like
merch some people don't like some people
are willing to pay on the care Spectrum
not really high over here and this is
where it gets really interesting or
important newsletter was uh something
that people like kind of expected for a
community they want some sort of regular
communication um but they weren't like
willing to pay a huge amount for it but
the big three that we're in here and so
I include this one as my number four by
the way because I still I want to make
sure I do that right
is they wanted exclusive access so that
means
q&as uh talking to experts they want to
be closer think proximity either
digitally or in person but just for the
sake of this conversation for digital
Community it's like they want to be able
to ask you questions and so that means
like they post and you respond or you
hop on a call and you respond any of
those things would count so number one
was access uh number two was content
meaning they like some of the stuff that
you put publicly they just want more of
that stuff privately that they can't get
somewhere else and so you have exclusive
access exclusive content um as the
second kind of bucket courses would fall
under this uh trainings things like that
and the final one which surprised me
actually uh was events and so people in
a community want to be able to meet up
they want to meet up in person you can
also do virtual events of course but I
think I think the real power is if you
can meet people in person have them fly
in or fly out to them depending on the
size of the community and so these are
the big four that people put into
communities to drive value is that I
will be the one talking to you I'll
respond to your stuff via DM I'll
respond to your posts inside the the
feed or I'll have calls on some regular
Cadence or you can expect some sort of
response time from me content here's
some additional training here's some
course here's some whatever that I can
put in here to provide even more value
now the content can also be in feed
meaning you can just write articles so
in the school games I prefer to be
written and so I actually write long
articles like probably two times a month
on one component of the school games
like hey if you're using ads is what I
would consider if you're getting
Partners here's a script that I wrote
for you guys to go get partners right so
that would be content and then events is
that you meet people together like that
one's pretty self-explanatory in the
newsletter you can actually just take
some of this content put in written
format email it out right very very easy
um and so School helps you do all four
of those things all in one
place when you were running gym launch
did Community feel like a really obvious
thing that increased a lot of value for
users like I'm wondering if that oh yeah
so this is really interesting so samon
consulting.com which is a which was a
relatively large um education business
and he found something really
interesting which is I think one of the
impetus God catalysts uh for for this uh
for him actually innovating the product
that that would eventually become school
is that when he looked at his user data
he saw that people would buy a course
but they would log in they'd watch a
handful of videos and then they would
spend the rest of their time in the
group and so they'd make content in the
group they'd ask questions in the group
almost everything the community really
was the group way less so the course but
everything that was out there was
focused on building the course rather
than the community being the core
component and so he flipped the priority
and said well what if we made Community
the main thing and just had all the
things that people like that surround
communities as I want to say add-ons but
like integrated into it but the
community is the Hub and so um yes with
gimm launch the community was obviously
a huge part of it I think works with any
any kind of business that's service
related or education related like I
still consider the gyms semi education
because a lot of people there trying to
learn more about how to eat healthy work
out better learn form learn cooking
recipes meal prep there are a lot of
other things that go into that lifestyle
and so a useful question for any
business owner is like what lifestyle am
I bringing people towards and so like if
I were teaching music there's a
musician's lifestyle there's probably
like a way that they schedule their time
there's there's tools that they use
there's ways that they practice all of
those things go along with the identity
that someone would have as a musician as
somebody who's a fitness person as an
author right and so one of the great
like business strategies just think like
what is the I am statement that
accompanies my product so like I am a
and then what comes along with that and
so if you can build a community around
that of people who also identify with
that label you have a much deeper
connection with them because they all
identify the same way how does making a
school group or taking this business
model uh compared to let's say something
like Drop Shipping or e-commerce like
any other thing that you yeah it depends
on the goal right and so if you're
trying
to if you're trying to make money on the
internet you want the thing with the
simplest business model that has the
lowest risk and the fewest moving parts
and I think school has that um I would
say I'm quote biased because I'm a
co-owner but like I honestly I I would
never risk my reputation to say
something for for I just wouldn't do it
so you can choose to believe that or not
from a selling perspective if you wanted
to have like a big exit in a business um
you have to prove that you have an asset
that is sellable that that works without
you now a school Community or community
in general if it's built off the face of
a Founder is going to have the same
issues of keyman risk that any business
that is built on a Founder would have
and so you would have to build a school
Community differently if you had that
intention now the vast majority of
people that consume my stuff um are
trying to just make a lot more money
than they currently are whether they're
by quitting their job to start something
or within their business they just want
to grow it now some people want to sell
which hey acis.com so we're here for
give us a call the main thing that
someone wants to buy in a business is
long-term recurring revenue is you want
to know that the people that are paying
today are going to pay four years from
now and so school isn't is it a salable
asset or not a sellable asset it's just
like any other recurring business how
good you are at it will dictate how
recurring it is and how valuable it is
and so I'll give you an example there's
a a I say an acquaintance of mine who
has a a business that Services uh
mechanic shops so really Niche he's got
10 locations so he knows what he's doing
he's not somebody who like started one
wasn't making money then started like
those who can't do teach he didn't go
that model like he has 10 locations he's
legit he's done a handful of rollups
like a very legitimate player and
because he is legit he has uh uh a
business that does I think just under
$50 million a year all on recurring
Community right and so if you have a
niche expertise that has super high
value and compared to everything else in
the marketplace you have all these
benefits that no one else has people
will stay and they'll continue to pay
and this guy is growing every single
year and so if I'm looking to acquire
company yes I'm super interested now on
the flip side if you create a community
and you don't provide value and people
cancel in two months then no it's not
going to be valuable you'll make an
income because you'll know how to Market
and you'll convert some sort you just do
number of new conversions per month
times average order value and you'll
you'll get how much money you're going
to make in terms of income but I would
say this is that if you're trying to get
going don't worry about that get the
first dollar across the bridge you'll
learn so many skills in just doing that
the next steps will become clear to you
once you take the first steps because
it's really easy to get overwhelmed in
the beginning just get the first dollar
across the line you have a huge
International audience yeah and I wonder
if part of this was being able to make
business accessible to people dude th%
yeah so we have right now 50% or
something like that of our total
audience is international um and so
having something that could also service
all of those people was a huge a huge
Boon um to why this also made sense for
me versus like if I had a physical
product thing and we were only in the US
then I would automatically cut out
probably 70% of the people that I could
potentially help oh and this is yeah and
a great Point too is that if you make
content on the internet for example as a
way to get customers you will also have
a certain percentage of your audience
that that is international and having
like a community for example as long as
everyone speaks the same language you
can provide value to them without having
to worry about International borders the
tariffs tax like you don't have to worry
about any of that stuff believe me I've
done international shipping it's a
nightmare also anyone can join the
school games and read your posts and
potentially come out to the headquarters
verus becoming a portfolio company is
yeah and one of the other things I
thought was kind of cool is um obviously
the only companies that we like really
directly interact with are companies
that we own but by having the school
games and you know the top 10 every
month of the school games and the cool
thing about the school games not to push
this too hard but um is that it's off of
new recurring Revenue meaning it's not
like oh these guys have been doing you
know school for five years and they win
every month if you win you get taken off
number one and number two it's based on
the new added Revenue so you can start
and in fact uh March of last month I
think four or five of the people who won
started that exact month now some people
started a handful of months ago and then
like took it seriously they like went
pro like they were like this is the
month I'm been try and win and they
really pushed it and then they did get
on the top 10 and then they're flying
out to Vegas to hang out um talk about
growing their business but like four of
them literally like they're like yep I
saw an ad and it was you know February
28th and then I was like I'm starting on
the 1 of March and they just did it one
guy met his business partner I think in
school and was like oh you know hor he's
a foreign guy he was like you know her
Moi yeah he's got the school games I'm
doing it and so he's like let's win and
they met and one guy handled the
delivery the other guy handled the
promotion a great partnership and they
came in 10th place they like just got in
um it was really cool very cool Russian
guy yeah really cool uh do you want to
talk a bit about like why Sam and yeah I
mean Sam he's
obsessive and so this is really
interesting for you so people have
probably heard the term OCD right
obsessive compulsive disorder first off
off I would drop the D and just say
someone's obsessive and compulsive it
doesn't mean it's a disorder unless it
affects their life uh negatively and I
would say many quote OCD people do
better than people who are not and so
why would it be a disorder but neither
here nor there so you have two
components there you have obsessiveness
and you have compulsiveness I think the
the ideal makeup of an entrepreneur
somebody who's obsessed but not
compulsive is that you can literally
hold your attention on this goal for
years and not compulsively change
direction not compulsively need to do
things to quell that you just are
obsessed with this one thing and Sam is
obsessed he wants to build the absolute
best product that is the most fun that
makes making money online and making
your first business as easy as possible
and seeing that Obsession and his
attention to detail throughout the many
months of conversation that we had
before we decided to uh before I decided
to you know Buy in um as a co-owner of
the company and then obviously promote
it uh publicly um I saw his obsession
and I felt like it mirrored mine in a
different vertical and I think from a
partnership perspective that's what you
want is that you want someone who's as
obsessed with you sorry as obsessed with
the with whatever they're good at as you
are with whatever you're good at what
you don't want is somebody who's as
obsessed with the same things as you are
because then one of you isn't necessary
and so perfect partnership typically
there's three big veins in a business
you've got product you've got promotion
and you've got people and so uh you want
somebody who who's who represents all
three of those now to be clear the
equity distribution doesn't need to be
third third third it could you could
have an employee who's exceptional like
you it's just those are the functions
that have to be maintained for business
to grow my last question is a little
like Easter egg for anyone who's made it
all the way to the end of the video from
the first couple school games are there
any like really amazing tips or tactics
that you've seen from people building
great communities and scaling Rel so
instead of tips or tactics I will say
that there's a lot of ways to win the
game and I think that is probably the
the metal lesson is that I have seen
people on the school school games who
only did email outbound they literally
did cold email got on the phone and sold
people into their Community now
obviously they have a higher ticket so
it's more like $500 month or $1,000 a
month for their Community but they won
the school games that way there were
people who already had organic audiences
and then just like basically made the
CTA and said hey put a ton of bonuses
ton of value in there and they were able
to take an audience that they basically
weren't making anything from and then
turn it into a community that they also
got paid for so they both deepen the
community and uh make make an income
from it so that's like the people who
had audiences there's also people who
ran ads to make this work uh there's
people and this is probably my favorite
model is there's these two guys uh mix
and fad who came in I think third or
third last time and neither of these
guys have social media presences at all
but they reached out to an influencer
that had like 50,000 followers and they
said hey we'll make we'll do everything
like we'll we'll edit your videos
will prompt you we'll record it and
we'll do the ctas we'll do everything
and we'll make this community and we'll
manage it and they grew him from 50 to 3
million so they're good at what they did
and they also started the school games
in the first month they made they added
like 40,000 in recurring Revenue uh or
50,000 or something like that uh in the
first month in recurring Revenue like
not like recurring Revenue so my point
is is like if I had to if I had to if I
had to start over tomorrow at zero if I
had to start over tomorrow at zero and I
didn't have any money and I had no
connections like no one knows me I have
no reputation the model that I would use
to win the games is I would use cold
reach outs two people who are
influencers to ask them to partner with
me because of that because the the hit
rate you only need one so from a success
percent you literally just need one and
the key and this is the pro tips if you
want an Easter egg this is it when you
do these reach outs every position has
an advantage and a disadvantage so I'm
going to zoom out for a second and
explain the advantage of the underdog
so when I had gym launch I had a guy who
so I had Allen to my software company
and we had so this is kind of funny but
I had agencies using one of our unique
selling props in their business that was
trying to compete with my business but
we were the underlying infrastructure
anyways and so they were like everybody
wants to buy your thing because you're
the big established player right and I
was like dude when I came in I wasn't
the big established player so what did I
say then so when you're coming in you
say man to Alex you're just a number
like you're never going to talk to him
like he just owns this thing like he's
just like it's just some representative
that he trained who's going to be on
your account like it's it's going to be
nothing with me you get all my attention
I'm going to be fully focused I only
have two other customers like you're
going to have all my attention that's
the advantage now if I'm Alex I'm going
to say this kid's in his mom's basement
he has no idea what he's doing there's a
reason that he only has two customers
because he doesn't know how to provide
value consistently we've systematized
this thing so we can consistently
produce the result everybody has an
advantage and everybody has a
disadvantage and so if you're getting in
even if you have zero customers here's
what I would say I would say listen I
don't want I started this with the
intention of not having lots of
customers I want to find a partner and
I'm going to devote everything I have to
just this anybody else is going to split
you and you're going to be in account to
them you'll get a rep but with me it's
just me and I'm going to build this
whole thing myself like you'll have my
cell phone we'll talk every day we can
do whatever you want I'm going to build
this thing and the way you prove it this
is the key point this is the the the
real nug is that when you do that
Outreach and you say it with that
perspective when you get on the phone
prepare don't get on the phone
and be like yeah I was thinking maybe we
like partner up on this thing like you
have this value and I have nothing like
this should be a great deal right like
no you get on and you do so much work
ahead of time like DM the people who are
commenting on their on their stuff get
on the phone with them say hey what kind
of community would you want take the
notes record the call if you do five of
those interviews and then you hop on
that call with that influencer and you
say hey I made this deck do you mind if
I show it to you they're going to be
like you made a deck about my business
and they're like you're like yeah I can
walk you through kind of the strategy I
was thinking about like the phases of
roll out that we could do and what I've
already talked to your customers about
what they want they're going to be
fascinated by the fact that you already
you might know something about their
customers that they don't and you know
how you do that you work it's work
that's how you do it but you literally
work so much that when you make the
claim that you will work hard for them
you are demonstrating that you will work
hard for them and so they will believe
you because fundamentally every person
just wants a hardworking partner right
you just you just have to get them to
believe that now anyone can say I'm
going to work my butt off I'm all in but
the the proof is stacked against you
because you have nothing and so you have
to make up for that now and here's the
here's the cave what if influencer
number one says no you do it again and
when you get on the phone with
influencer number two guess what you do
you show the thing you built for
influencer number one as an example and
then you show theirs and if they say no
what do you do when you go to influencer
number two you show the stuff from
influen number one and number two and
then you show there so you're actually
building out a portfolio of stuff but
you have an incentive to make it
exceptional cuz you're never going to
present it to somebody so like you win
either way the only way you lose is if
you don't work and I promise you that on
a long enough time Horizon if you reach
out to these people and you get on the
phone with one and I'm I don't think
this is a key point I would not shoot
outside of your your league all right
like if you've never done this before I
wouldn't say go after a 5 million person
account I just don't think that's a
smart idea but I think if you go after a
50 or 100,000 150,000 person account and
to be clear you want to make sure
they're getting engagement it's not like
bot you know bot account or whatever but
you want to real person who and like you
want to know the real secret go to
somebody you already follow go to
somebody you already like cuz then you
won't be bsing when you talk to them
you're like I love this stuff about your
brand I think this would fit in in this
way and you know had that thing two
months ago I think this would be perfect
with that and I talked to a bunch of my
my friends who also follow you and I
talked to these other people just so it
wasn't just my friends and these are the
things that they were looking for and I
think that if we did this here's an
estimate like if we convert 1% of your
audience over it's this much a month I
think that'd be interesting and so you
probably follow 2,000 people now anyways
so just pick a hundred of them or pick
50 or if you really want to be targeted
Pick 10 and think to yourself if I had
to get one of these 10 will would I do
and then do that and I promise you
you'll get one and then from there you
have a partner and then you get the
leverage of the fact that they spent
five years building Their audience and
you get to have a part of that today
even if you only get 20% right now of
course you have to negotiate that piece
but my recommendation is don't be greedy
up front get the deal done get the Reps
in your belt because also being real you
don't know what you're doing and so I
wouldn't try and ask for the majority of
this
until you have some reps under your belt
right so take a smaller percentage use
it to build your portfolio in terms of
your proof that you're good you learn at
zillion things along the way and you're
going to get paid to learn and so if all
this school stuff sound interesting to
you um I do have an easy offer for you
you can go to
school.com games and what we have inside
for you is we have three calls a week
with guys who are actually making tens
of hundreds of thousands of dollars a
month on school using the platform
teaching you exactly what they did step
by step so we've got calls for you of
other people we've got a community of
others to help you out um and I think
the benefit here is that you get people
who are both starting with you at zero
but people who are also at the end of
the race cheering you on and so you kind
of have like three types of
accountability so you've got peer
accountability you've got kind of like
coach accountability because people are
are are rooting for you but then you
also have alumni accountability people
who've already been through it and then
uh I made a course that I put in there
it's free it just shows you how to to do
this the different ways to play the game
the different kind of like avatars that
you can self- select maybe I'm somebody
who likes making content maybe I'm
somebody who's better at ads maybe I'm
somebody who already has an audience
maybe I'm somebody who likes outbound um
maybe I'm somebody who likes to have a
partner so I break down all the
different paths that you can use to
really start making money on the
internet with what I think is the
easiest business model uh out there the
best part in my opinion is that all of
this
stuff obviously we have the prizes the
top 10 uh gets fly out so hopefully you
can do that but you only need three
people and I just did a one day full
deep dive it's eight hours of me just
helping the top 10 communities scale and
those recordings are live right now so
if I had a $100,000 Mastermind or
something this would be it except it's
yours and it's free and here's the
here's my incented for you if you just
get three people into your group all
right so I like to put a like as low as
I possibly could you get three people
into your group you can get your friends
in there I don't care if you cheated
it's fine get three people into your
community uh and you get the all the
downloads from that and all of this
stuff you can start for
free for 14 days just so you can get a
feel for it you can go in there and
download everything and steal it all for
all I care all right but my hope is that
you actually use it so you can make your
first dollar and I'll just repeat this
one stat because I think it's the most
important stat I think of the business
right now is that 34 30.4% of people who
finish their first month of the school
games make their first dollar online
it's about as compelling as I can get so
check it out school.com games see you
there I'm also on the inside of the
group too so hit me up tag me whatever